this pillar here is glitching big time
for me where to me yeah it looks like a
pillar what wait that's some collateral
damage okay you're gonna have to pay for
that yeah okay science I'm not a traitor
I was sciencing you bastard well I saw
minx came rampaging in through the door
catching me and yamimash off guard is we
were making out alone and unarmed and
she murdered us both Wow killed us
incredibly steamy in here yes that was
me and Yaya sorry I might die right now
hold on let me back up
Oh nowhere near you guys you guys me
already
whatever this is pretty matrix I don't
know I thought you were I thought you
were looking at a queue with me I
apologize
I thought you were skyping to get all
three okay hang on
somehow really big and I didn't realize
[Music]
minx meets it's why why can't you look
at him are you is that where you sit on
a dude's face over and over again
that's not CPR that's called blunt-force
trauma hold on bring the lift up and
then we'll put his gun I wish I did I
think mix has the good in a pocket and
she's pretending I think she has four in
her pocket there's an explosive barrel
here hang on I got it let's all guys
let's all fun next to the explosive
barrel please change map I'm gonna blow
you whoa there
trouble in terrorist on YouTube is
really really good look good that's the
only time we're allowed to do a cover
yeah so basically any cover of baby got
back is golden get off the stage
[Laughter]
there's a traitor in the Bruce
Springsteen impersonator over here in
the lounge area it was not me
no that's the Internet why is it coming
to hear my singing the killing burner
people that criticize you I'm gonna
bring your body I'll throw it off into
the ocean and just assume symbolic
gesture of goodwill
all right and body on the diving board
so no one uses the diag more cuz this is
my diving board allowance cuz I didn't
like his [ __ ] he wasn't the terrorist
he's just really bad at taking criticism
right back here
hey hey hey in the back where you can't
aim at me yo maybe I'm gonna sing and
you're good
[Laughter]
you as a trader last time so that the
big fashion girl and none of these girls
are big what a joke that [ __ ] on me you
can frame me I can't fairy I can frame
you you can't frame money I think makes
is the trader I'm staying the [ __ ] out
of this are you
a likely story acting over there simply
for that sound
[Laughter]
good job so babies bark
[Music]
Oh
I'm sorry for the screams by the way
guys get off my head I'm shooting your
vagina
okay that's a good way of getting them
uncropped yes well the best way to deal
with cramps just shoot that [ __ ]
[Laughter]